[Music]
marissa
is with us in trenton hi marissa how are
you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so i am 29 years old i have been working
as a nurse for the last six years i am
a single mom my daughter is six years
old
and i made the big financial
commitment to go back to nurse
anesthesia school wow
so yeah um i paid off my undergraduate
loan which was 30
000 my parents did help me and support
me through the way
um that was paid before going into
school as well as my car and i have no
credit card debt
the school now will cost me about
250 000 and with interest it'll be about
300
000 um i've been with my boyfriend for
about
four years and besides paying back alone
we're looking to get married in the next
few years
and have more kids so i just wanted to
see
what your thoughts were on coming up
with a plan
i think i could realistically pay off
this almost 300
000 in the next three to five years but
it's very daunting and i don't know how
to balance that with
having a wife getting married and having
more kids at the same time
okay um you've been listening to us not
a long time i take it
for the past few months my boyfriend
actually turned me onto the show and
i've been listening
few a few hours every single day i just
don't know how to make the baby steps
really work for me
i saved thirty thousand dollars to live
on
for the three years that i'm in school
yeah
okay um
well to start with let's pretend that
you had already graduated and you had
this loan
you would have you'd be making how much
three hundred thousand a year right
two hundred thousand a year where um
we're in training i would start at 205.
okay and you make what now
i actually just stopped working because
what were you making when you just
stopped working
i was making 75 okay all right which
makes a
difference of 140 000 so you could be
you could pay off 300 000
in two years if you continue to live
like you were living right before you
stopped working
yeah which would be what i would tell
you to do
were you already here but you're not
already here
in 30 years of doing this show i've
never told anyone to go into debt to go
to school and i'm not going to start
today
so i'm mr dream killer today i
love the idea of you being a nurse
anesthetist
i love the idea of your income going
from 75 to 205 and i think those are
accurate numbers by the way i don't
think you're living in a dream world i
think that's about right based on what i
the number of nurse anesthetists i have
coached over the years
and by the way i think i think 205 is
this floor i think that's starting i
think it'll head towards 300 pretty
quick
especially if you pick up ot and other
things you could knock that debt out
very quickly
the problem comes into play in that
you're talking to a guy
who has coached people where this plan
didn't work
that your mother
became ill your child became ill you
became ill
there was a car wreck there was
something and your
200 000 into this and you don't complete
or you get married you have more babies
and you want to stay home
and you don't want to work at all which
you don't know what you're going to want
in three years or five years with a
different family and situation but you
have that debt
anyway i just want to clarify i'm
actually in the program already i'm in
the second year of the program
oh so you've already taken that loan
that was not what you said
yeah i'm confused you've already taken
out the loan for the program you're
you're in it
i'm in it i'm in the second year so
we're living off my boyfriend's income
he makes
90 000. by the time i'm finished he'll
make 130 000.
um so i'm not paying for living expenses
right now i'm living off my savings
and we're planning when i graduate to
put all of my paychecks towards the loan
and he continues to pay for living okay
when are y'all getting married that's
the thing
um i think he he says we
probably would have been doing that now
we really push everything off
because of my going back to school
taking out this
why are you going back to school keep
you from getting married
you just go down and get married
we want a really small wedding okay then
just go get married
go tomorrow
what's this painter get off the ladder
yeah and we're renting right now i don't
know what's that got to do with it
renters get married all the time
yeah i just feel guilty i don't have any
money to put towards a wedding
or a house listen whether you're married
or not
you have nothing to feel guilty about
you're playing house you might as well
get a piece of paper that says it's okay
it's going to bring a different level of
being a team and attacking these
financial goals together when you're
really afraid for you i mean if he
decides to walk off there's nothing
if he decides to walk off you're screwed
i i could live with my my parents if if
i had to
you kind of missed the point didn't you
oh you mean with paying back the loan
okay
so um yeah i i don't know what the
question is now i think you're
i think you have your plan and i guess
you need to execute your plan uh it
would be a different plan than christy
and i would sign you up for
uh we hope good things for you we want
good things for you we're not mad at you
we don't want anything
but to come to you but blessings but um
yeah i the these plans of going this far
into debt to get a
valid degree with a great income like
becoming an attorney or becoming a
medical doctor or becoming a nurse
anesthetist
they only work when they work
but the guy that didn't pass the bar
four times will tell you
that that 185 000 worth of law school
debt is not a freaking guarantee
so i i just i worry for you kid i just
don't want bad things to happen for you
i hope it all works out i hope it all
plays through
i hope you come out making 205 he's
making 135 and he finally gets around to
marrying you or you finally get around
to marrying him
and then you've got a 340 000 or 50 000
household income and you pay off this
300 in like
one year 18 months 24 months that's what
i would do
but um you know i if that's your
question yeah that's what i would do i
would attack it like a vengeance and the
first thing you need to do is quit
borrowing
if he's got enough income coming in and
you're sharing income as if you're
married i wouldn't recommend that
but apparently that's what you're doing
so then maybe if he's got 130 coming in
maybe you don't have to type borrows a
dead gun much
if you're married it'd be no question
that would be what you should do
i'm not sure he should pay for his
girlfriend's education though
matter of fact i'm sure he shouldn't let
me try that again i've never told
anybody do that either
so i get so confused
you're like what what am i saying what
question are we in what about what have
i committed
to what have i signed up for how did we
get here
man i'm just oh okay so
um here's the deal let's backtrack a
second
because we have about a minute before
the break so let's say you're out there
and you're facing this exact dilemma
the mountainous amount of tuition
to get a an equal mountainous amount of
income if it all works out perfectly
and sometimes it does admittedly but it
doesn't always we all have to admit that
and we can't act like it's 100
right it's a lock it's not a lock
doesn't always happen
maybe there's another way to get at this
maybe you're working for a hospital
company who wants you to commit to being
their nurse anesthetist which they're
recruiting for and having trouble
getting right now
and you promise to stay there three
years in return
they promised to pay your tuition and
you prom you don't go ahead and lock
down a
contractual rate at which you're willing
to work um
that way you don't have any debt so the
ways around it yeah you know or
maybe you get a fellowship and you're
working a fellowship
at a mid school and you're teaching grad
classes and other things while you're
doing this
and you get through it yeah maybe you
work overtime like crazy as a nurse and
pile up lots and lots and lots of money
and you pay cash
for your education but it takes you
three years longer
and you don't have all the risk these
are the things we would tell someone
facing similar situations to do this is
the ramsay show